Hello
你聽過吃香蕉
吃到出大事的嗎
嘿 前一段時間
香蕉便宜到不行
一根只要台幣2、3塊錢
有個女生為了省錢
一天三餐
就香蕉給它過去了
竟然一天吃了
二十一根香蕉
結果當晚就不舒服了
失去意識昏倒
醒來到醫院去 醫生說
鉀離子濃度過高
鉀中毒
哇 慘兮兮哦
我跟你說
不要為了省錢
而賠上健康
待會兒我要告訴你
有三種狀況不要吃香蕉
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
這集要跟你分享
3狀況別吃香蕉
嘿 恐致命
1時段吃香蕉
止餓又好眠
香蕉和兩物一起煮
暖腸通便
服用1種降壓藥
注意要少吃香蕉
嘿 我跟你說
香蕉可不是那隨便的水果
它裡面鉀的元素
就是potassium很強大
能把你體內
多餘的鹽份排掉
讓血壓更穩定
心臟也不會太累
血壓容易高高低低的人
吃個香蕉
能夠調整血壓
吃多少
1天吃半根就好了
半根大概就是
95公克不到100克
又安全又有用
誰不適合吃香蕉呢
請注意
正在吃保鉀型降壓藥的人
香蕉要少吃
避免血鉀過高
一般降壓藥
就大概沒啥問題
那還有粉絲會問
血壓高的人能吃香蕉
血糖高的人能不能吃呢
Of course
美國糖尿病協會建議
糖友們可以適量吃香蕉
因為香蕉的纖維能穩定血糖
糖友們
吃香蕉還有個小技巧
就是吃那種
還沒完全熟的
帶點綠色的那種香蕉
這樣的香蕉啊
升糖指數比較低
能更好的控制血糖
不過血糖高的人
一次不要吃超過半根
份量要抓好喔
每天吃香蕉竟然吃到昏迷
3種狀況不要吃
你去超商能喝到
韓國的香蕉牛奶
去夜市可以吃到
去夜市可以
香蕉人人都能吃嗎
不是啦
三種情況 不吃
第一 腎功能不好的時候
第二 脾胃虛寒的時候
第三 正在咳嗽的時候
最好不要吃
腎不好的人
為什麼不能多吃香蕉
因為香蕉啊
它鉀含量很高
每100公克就有368毫克
滿多的
對慢性腎病或是
血鉀偏高的人來說
吃了可能
引發生命的危機
有一個真實案例
一個太太啊
大約60歲
她有三高和腎臟病
每天都會吃一根香蕉
有一天
鉀離子竟然飆到7.2
當場昏迷 緊急送醫
哇 怎麼會這樣呢
鉀太高會引發心律不整
嚴重的時候
心臟完全沒反應
還好 醫師施打藥物之後
她醒是醒過來了
之後透過洗腎
順利的把鉀降下來
所以如果你家裡人
有腎臟不好
一定要提醒他
不要貪吃香蕉
賠了命就不好囉
第2 脾胃虛寒的人不要吃
香蕉是寒性食物
如果你容易
拉肚子 胃痛 胃酸過多
甚至於消化性的潰瘍
就不要吃香蕉
吃了會更嚴重
冬天手腳冰冷 臉色蒼白
嘴唇淡白的人
淡淡的白色的人
更要少碰香蕉
免得腸胃不舒服
以前阿嬤們常說
筋骨不好的人
不能吃香蕉
為什麼
其實也是和脾胃有關係
脾胃功能比較弱的人
身體水份代謝就不太好
關節容易僵硬
動作不靈活
所以香蕉也不能吃太多喔
第3 咳嗽
什麼水果不能吃
香蕉
因為香蕉會生痰
加重咳嗽
像是橘子 鴨肉 冰品
這些食物咳嗽的時候
也暫時不要吃
焦慮睡不好
這個時間吃香蕉
睡得香香
你知道嗎
這樣一根香蕉
就有10毫克的色胺酸
色胺酸是什麼好東西
色胺酸進入了大腦以後
先變成所謂的快樂因子
血清素
再轉成助眠的荷爾蒙
褪黑激素
能夠讓你更快的入睡
更能延長深層的
睡眠的時間
讓你一覺到天亮
什麼時候吃香蕉
助眠最有效
建議你下午3、4點的時候
吃香蕉最好
這個時候肚子有一點點餓
你是不是
正想來一片餅乾啊
不要吃啦
不要吃餅乾
你放下零食
來吃一根香蕉
坐辦公室的人吃香蕉
不沾手很方便
一打開就能吃了
能夠止飢餓
晚上還能睡得很香
是不是很棒的零食選擇
吃香蕉難通便
和兩物一起煮 暖腸通便
一位網友分享
他喝了超商推出的
香蕉火龍果牛奶
腸道超順暢
簡直就是腸道的外送
但如果你吃香蕉
腸道還是一點都沒動
別擔心
試試這個小偏方
你準備一根青皮的香蕉
不是這種黃皮的啊 青皮的
再拿3片這個陳皮
陳皮啊就是橘子皮
在藥房裡頭
可以買得到的東西
適量的像這個冰糖
煮成陳皮香蕉湯
暖暖的喝下去
幫助腸道活絡起來
這一碗湯能夠通便
潤肺 理氣
大人小孩都可以喝
是不是蠻棒的
青皮香蕉 溫中潤腸
幫助排便不燥
就大便不燥會潤一點
陳皮又能夠理氣消滯
讓腸道動起來
冰糖還能夠潤喉養肺
你會問我
體質虛寒的人
不是不能吃香蕉嗎
沒錯 但是食物真的很神奇
香蕉煮過之後
它的寒性就給去掉了一點
變得溫和一些
這樣一來
即便手腳冰冷
脾胃虛寒的人
也可以放心喝它一碗吧
香蕉清熱解毒 全身是寶
用它治腹痛 皮膚癢
你有沒有聽過阿嬤說
失戀愛吃香蕉皮了
聽起來好像是笑話對不對
香蕉皮怎麼能吃呢
阿嬤可沒有在隨便講喔
香蕉皮真的能吃
還能入藥
香蕉皮怎麼吃
你逛夜市的時候
有些攤販會把香蕉皮
炸得香香脆脆的
或是你可以用帶皮的香蕉
加牛奶打成香蕉牛奶
要記得喔
皮一定要洗乾淨
不洗乾淨怎麼能吃對不對
好 才能夠避免農藥殘留
古人早就知道
香蕉皮的厲害
把香蕉皮當成藥材
廣東中藥記載
香蕉皮炒一炒煮水喝
能治腸胃炎引起的
突發腹痛
香蕉皮煮水拿來擦洗
能夠止皮膚癢
舒緩紅疹
香蕉葉也有妙用
太平聖惠方裡頭記載說
可以把香蕉葉研磨成粉
加上薑汁來調勻
塗在腫脹或小膿包上面
能夠消腫止痛喔
再來說說香蕉根
備急千金要方
它記載
香蕉根很寒涼
用來清熱解毒
專治因為火氣過盛
而長出的膿瘡
也就是我們現在講的痘痘對不對
和發炎等等
你看小小一根香蕉
從皮 果肉 葉子 還有到根
全身都是寶
所以下次吃香蕉
記得香蕉皮不要亂丟
不只是會讓人滑倒
還浪費好東西啦
香蕉運動前
還是運動後吃比較好呢
你有沒有
發現很多運動員
運動到一半
就拿出一根香蕉
大口咬下
那可是他們的能量
補給秘密武器呀
香蕉要在運動前吃
還是運動後吃
哪個比較好呢
其實兩個時間都有好處
運動前30分鐘
到一個小時吃香蕉
有天然的糖份 鉀
能夠快速補充能量
讓你不會運動到一半
哈哈沒力氣了
或者是抽筋了
運動後1個小時吃香蕉呢
能補回流失的鉀和糖份
幫助肌肉恢復 減少痠痛
提醒你哦
如果你是在做高強度運動的人
運動前只要吃半根香蕉就好
太多容易覺得胃脹不舒服